desde Jacarandas están pidiendo la
nulidad de la decisión de la corte
Cuáles consideran que son los puntos más
preocupantes de la sentencia
Bueno estamos muy preocupadas porque
la sentencia que que del año pasado fue
histórica desnalizó el aborto hasta la
semana 24 y en esta oportunidad es una
sala de revisión es decir tres
magistrados decidieron que decir como
desapartarse de varias cosas de ese de
esa decisión del núcleo esencial de esa
decisión y por eso nosotros pensamos que
debe ser nula de de hay como un montón
de incoherencias argumentativas de lo
que se dijo el año pasado y de lo que se
dice esta y por eso pedimos que pues que
no se generen barreras para las mujeres
indígenas porque uno podría concluir que
hay más requisitos para Acceder al
aborto para mujeres indígenas y para las
mujeres que no somos indígenas es mucho
más fácil precisamente sobre este tema
Cómo puede esto llegar a afectar a las
mujeres indígenas en su autonomía
bueno las mujeres indígenas a partir de
esta decisión en especial si están
afiliadas a la eps del cauca deben pedir
que el resguardo se pronuncie para
acceder a la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo lo cual viola su autonomía el
secreto profesional la confidencialidad
la intimidad y pues pues somete que un
colectivo se tenga que ratificar una
decisión que es netamente individual
como continuar o no el embarazo lo cual
nos preocupa de sobremanera y desde
jacaran las planean algún tipo de acción
para los próximos días
Pues nosotros presentamos una acción
judicial contactamos a la peticionaria y
le brindamos apoyo legal ella estuvo de
acuerdo con presentar la nulidad le
parece una decisión injusta y estamos
planeando más estrategias para más
adelante que incluye movilización social